So at this point the training of my support vector classifier is done,
including the principle components transformation.
Now I want to move on to testing.
In order to do that, I need to repeat what I did with my training features,
this time with my testing features.
And that means starting with a PCA transform.
Something very important that I'm not doing here,
is refitting my PCA on my test features.
I want to be very consistent between what I've done with the training features,
and what I'll be doing with the testing features here.
So that means using the same principle components that I found in the training
features and representing my testing features using those principle components.
So that having been said, when I call PCA to a transform,
do I want to be doing it on the training features or on the testing features?